well if you keep track of the happenings
over at the American ornithological
society as I'm sure you do then you
already know all about the momentous
announcement the organization made this
week but if for some reason you are not
up to speed on the latest developments
in the bird watching Community then you
may be in the dark about this and in
fact just now hearing that there was
some kind of significant event in the
Ornithology space you're probably
assuming that a major bird related
breakthrough has occurred has the
American ornithological society
discovered a new species of bird that
will redef society's expectations of
what a bird can be or maybe they
identified a new invasive bird that's
going to destroy all the crops and bring
about the end of civilization perhaps
there's something more salacious
happening in the Aven World Maybe Taylor
Swift is dating a famous bird watcher
maybe she's dating a bird these are all
logical guesses but that is where the
disappointment sets in it turns out the
big announcement uh instead was this
after more than two years of
deliberation this bird Society has
decided that at long last they're going
to decolonize the Hobby of bird watching
in all related fields and they're going
to to do that by changing the names of a
few dozen birds as USA Today reported
without the slightest hint of irony or
self-awareness quote dozens of birds to
be renamed an effort to shun racism and
make science more
diverse now after realizing how absurd
that headline was USA Today quickly
changed it later in the day and now the
headline reads quote dozens of birds
including ones named after white
supremacist are being renamed
the article goes on to explain that
quote the society plans to remove all
human names from the common names for
Birds within its jurisdiction to create
a more inclusive environment for people
of diverse backgrounds interested in
bird watching and Ornithology the public
process yet to be fully defined will
include 70 to 80 birds in the US and
Canada according to the society the New
York Times elaborated on the situation
with their own article quote Advocates
of this change believe that many English
common names for birds are isolating and
demeaning reminders of Oppression
slavery and genocide according to a
petition of in 2020 that was addressed
to the American orni ornithological
society the petition was written by bird
names for Birds an initiative founded by
two ornithologists to confront the issue
of these bird names which it describes
as verbal
statues so they're going to tear down
the verbal statues just like they tore
down the actual statues and they'll make
sure that no bird is named after a human
at least not any white human and that
means there will be no more macau's long
spur that's a bird named after John P
Macau who discovered it but John John P
mcau fought for the Confederacy and he
didn't want the seminal Indians to rule
Florida so needless to say the name of
that particular bird needs to change the
Scots orial also needs a new identity
because it was named after Winfield
Scott who relocated Indians in the 19th
century in the so-called Trail of Tears
and of course there are the birds named
for John James oton who basically
created the whole field of modern
Ornithology and that needs to change as
well because he owns slaves that's a big
problem for the aabon sheerwater which
is a bird that lives off the coast of
Southern United States as I'm sure you
know now it goes without saying of
course that these bird names um have
caused Untold trauma for bird watchers
and civilians alike it's impossible to
know just how many people have collapsed
in shock and suffered heart attacks
after learning that uh you know a
species of North American Sparrow was
named after an obscure Civil War General
or that a certain type of crow Bears the
name of a guy who owned slaves 265 years
ago or whatever but we all we also give
less thought to the birds themselves who
um have for decades been saddled with
these ostracizing names and think of how
difficult that must be for them that's
why the American or ornithological
Society is getting rid of these
genocidal names and instead using names
that describe a bird's physical features
now granted it's only a matter of time
before that becomes a problem too now I
can't think of any reason why the name
Blackbird is racist but I'm sure
somebody will think of one it just may
take a while indeed it took more than
two years for these bird experts to make
this decision to rename all these birds
and they still haven't renamed them by
the way they've just confirmed that
they're going to do it if you run a
small business you need to plan ahead
one of the best ways to do that is by
using stamps.com for all your mailing
and shipping needs stamps.com lets you
print your own Postage and shipping
labels right from your office or your
home your shipping labels are ready to
go in minutes so you can uh get back to
running your business sooner we don't
waste time here at Daily wire we've used
stamps.com since 2017 our office
management staff loves stamps.com
because they don't have to spend hours
at the post office stamps.com offers
rates you can't find anywhere else like
up to 84% off use USPS and UPS plus they
will automatically tell you your
cheapest and fastest shipping options
for 25 years stamps.com has been
indispensable to over 1 million
businesses you can print postage
wherever you do business no lines no
traffic no waiting they even send you a
free scale so you'll have everything you
need to get started set your business up
for Success get started with stamps.com
today sign up with promo code Walsh for
a special offer that includes a 4-week
trial plus free postage and free digital
scale no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code
Walsh more than two years ago the
Washington Post published a deep dive
into the field of bird watching noting
that many birds carry a quote racist
Legacy and now two years later we have
some results almost this is how long the
process takes to give Birds more
politically correct names for comparison
it took less than 3 weeks to write the
Declaration of Independence but again
the de but but then again the
Declaration of Independence is not
nearly as important a document as the
Declaration of anti-racist bird names
from the American ornithological
society now if you want to know more
about this laborious process of
identifying the racist birds and I'm
sure you do I have a clip uh from the
American ornithological society meeting
two years ago where they first disc
discussed this issue the meeting was
hosted by a woman named Amelia Juliet
demory who's a member of the American
orthological society's diversity and
inclusion committee and yes the American
ornithological society really does have
a diversity and inclusion committee I'm
not making that up somehow I'm not
making any of this up now if you thought
that regular human diversity inclusion
committees were useless well wait till
you get a load of the diversity
inclusion committee for
birds actually I must admit that the
video of this bird diversity meeting is
two hours long and I was not committed
enough to endure more than a very short
snippet so I kind of just started at a
random timestamp and watched for about
90 seconds and this is the part that I
saw
watch so I'm a professional communicator
and talking about birds like Bachman
Sparrow are really challenging because
it looks like another Sparrow why should
someone that doesn't think it's super
cool care about this this
near-threatened species right well if we
could all get excited about you know we
have to do this Community Education
aspect to this campaign for it's now the
most awesome Sparrow instead of a
sparrow that represents a Lutheran ptor
that talked about white supremacy then
that's really cool too and maybe we can
do really cool art and storytelling and
get the community involved and talk
about again the threats and conservation
needs that birds have maybe we can talk
about some of the stories and
experiences that um the bird community
members that aren't represented today
have with this bird and all of the other
ones I just think that it's exciting
what our future could be especially
because I think the biggest opportunity
is that this could be our chance to have
a concrete statement say the tendrils of
all social justice have reached to the
point of bird names and we're going to
do something about it no it won't end
RAC ISM it won't fix colonialism but
it's something that we can do right now
today as our community and the bird
Community is so big the impact of this
could be
massive that is the saddest video I've
ever seen in my life I find it sad on
such a deep level it's hard to even
express now a couple of things here I
I I am not going to say anything about
the guy on the lower right hand Corner
uh I I well I did just say something
about him but I'm not going to say
anything
else all I will say is that he's exactly
what you imagine when you hear that bird
watchers have a diversity and inclusion
committee somehow that guy in particular
manifests in your mind before you even
see him and uh and that's all I'm going
to say also this fact may interest only
me but I want you to know that the title
of this video on YouTube is AOS
community Congress on English bird names
it is as mentioned 2 hours long it's
been on YouTube for 2 years and it has
1,700 views and it's monetized they are
running ads on that video I don't know
what profit potential they thought this
content had but I hope that it lived up
to those expectations in any case this
is Big Stuff the lady says this is
massive this is Major they are changing
bird names sure sure she acknowledged it
won't end racism it won't fix
colonialism it won't Usher in a
progressive Utopia on its own it will
only get us like 95% of the way there to
get us the rest of the way we're going
to have to rename a bunch of racist
insects and bugs too but that would
require those Slackers and the
entomological society to get their act
together finally and confront this
problem and it's about time for that but
the bird lady uh did say one thing worth
thinking about she said with great pride
that the tendrils of social justice have
reached bird
names that is indeed how how pervasive
wokeness has become it has reached into
every corner of society and infected
every institution even organizations of
bird
watchers the revolution demands total
compliance everywhere among everyone
even birds are not exempt everything
must be brought into Conformity
everything must be changed redefined
renamed that is the dark reality
underpinning this otherwise absurd and
intent unintentionally hilarious story
but we don't need to focus on that for
now instead let's just point and laugh
at this because sometimes that's all you
can do or should do and we can also say
to the American ornithological society
what I never thought we'd have to say to
the American ornithological society
because frankly I never thought we'd
have to say anything to the American
ornithological society you are today
canceled thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast